- I know like three woman that
have kept their last name.
Beyonce, is Beyonce Knowles-Carter now.
She's not Beyonce Carter,
so I think the trend is
already starting to change.
(upbeat music)
- I think there is a
power dynamic that exists
when one person takes on
the other person's name.
- For you to take someone else's last name
shows a huge commitment to that person.
- I'm a traditionalist.
I would take my husband's last name.
- The prospect of coming
up with a name together
is really cool.
It's creating an identity
together is really neat.
- I like hyphenating,
I know it's like weird.
- I love my last.
If I were to marry a man or a woman,
I would keep my last name.
(upbeat music)
- Please imagine the following.
- You have been invited by an old friend
to an outdoor potluck picnic in the park.
- When you arrive you
say hello to your friend.
- Add the doughnuts you brought
to the large array of food.
- And then settle down on a big blanket
to eat and hang out.
- As soon as you sit down,
you meet a couple who
is sitting next to you.
(upbeat music)
- Michael Robertson and
his wife Carla Robertson.
his wife Carla Williams,
she kept her last name
when they got married.
(upbeat music)
- They've been together for three years
and married for one.
- As you chat with them you
learn more about their lives.
- Michael tells you about
the epic honeymoon they took.
- Carla shows you pictures
of their two dogs.
- Michael explains his job to you.
- Carla shares stories
from their experience
volunteering for local events.
(Upbeat music)
- So Carla Robertson,
caring I gave her a six.
- Intelligent, four.
Ambitious, three.
- Caring, I put five.
Carla was the one that showed
pictures of their dogs.
To me it came off more like
she was the caring one.
- Assertive, I put three.
- Independent, three.
- Quiet, four.
(upbeat music)
- List three jobs you think
Carla Robertson might have.
I originally put down unemployed,
because she talked about volunteer work.
- The first thing I said was a nurse,
because I said over her
that she was really caring.
- HR, receptionist.
- And then interior design.
I don't know, she seemed
artistic, maybe, too.
- How much money would you estimate
Carla Robertson makes per year?
$0 to $40K per year.
- I put $70,000.
- $55,000.
(upbeat music)
- Carla Williams intelligent, six.
Ambitious, six.
- Ambitious, five.
- Ambitious, six.
- Assertive, six.
Independent, six.
- Confident, six.
You got to be pretty
confident and independant
to want to keep her name,
so go in the face of
societal norm that way.
- Independent, six.
Quiet, one.
- List three jobs you think
Carla Williams might have.
- I feel like they're
a professional couple.
- I said CEO.
She just seems like she's
just about her business,
but yet she's still a loving wife,
and you can have both worlds.
- Business woman, politics, or professor.
- Engineer.
- Involved in advertising.
- Or an accountant.
- Or a professor.
- How much money would you
estimate Carla Williams
makes per year.
$70K.
- $80,000 per year.
- $75,000, $75K.
(upbeat music)
- Like our subconscious
perception of things
are so crazy and we don't even realize
that we're making these
judgments on people.
- Whenever I hear of the wife
taking the husband's name,
or the wife keeping her name,
or the husband taking the wife's name,
I do instantly make assumptions as to who
would be wearing the
pants in the relationship.
- So the fact that these two characters
kept their last name was really cool,
because the marriage didn't define them.
They were still their own individuals,
they were just in it together.
- I think it's cool, if my wife wanted to
keep her last name.
I think it would be awesome.
- If my sister were to keep her last name,
I'd be like, "You go girl."
- When I meet a woman
who's kept her last name,
I just assume that she's just a boss.
- I like to think of myself as
like a strong independent lady.
And I'm not taking anybody's
last name but my own.
- I don't think you should be judged
by if you change your last name
to someone else's last name.
- It's not your life.
It's somebody else's life
If you just be your baddass selves,
and it's okay if you're Mr. Robertson
or a Mrs. Jones, whoever.
You do you.